Grapes are a popular fruit that holds
great potential for us in North Dakota.
Here to teach us the basics of growing
grapes in our state is Dr. Harleen
Hatterman Valente. Harleen was born in
Nebraska and raised on a crop and animal
farm. And then she came to North Dakota
in 2000 as an assistant professor in the
high value crops project. Harleen has
conducted research on over 20 crops, but
grapes have been one of the most
predominant crops throughout her 25
years at North Dakota State University.
Harleen, welcome to the forums. Okay,
thank you Tom. Welcome. Okay, so we're
gonna get started here. So the goal in
this next 15 minutes is that going to
see handouts or slides where suggest
grapes that'll overwinter in North
Dakota. Very important. Determine some
of those cultural practices that'll help
you grow those grapes. Also very
important.
Um, if they don't ripen, I suppose in
jelly and juice, you could still add
more sugar and make that work, but to
have the best quality, you want to go
and have ripe grapes. Thus, going to
those first
two is very important. And if you get
all three of those, you'll probably get
this fourth one.
So site selection, a lot of us don't
have a choice. I just bringing this up
so that if you did have a choice,
there's some things you want to avoid.
Um, so if you are able to have that 1
and a half to 3% slope, you're going to
that's going to help move that cold air
down to the bottom. You don't want to be
down in that bottom. You could see on
the uh on that picture on the left hand
side your vineyard if
it's not in the bottom now you can be at
35 to 40 degrees there while someone who
had something to lower is going to go
and um get froze out. And I I've seen
this happen more in Montana where
actually I have some big differences in
terrain and in which they actually did
put grapes into a low area. It was a
nice flat level low area, but they had
this huge mountain that you know that
cold air would just come down.
um you can go and uh avoid that those
kind of frosts about 3 weeks if you're
on those hillsides instead of those
valleys. So big important thing if you
can get it on a south slope you're going
to um be able to uh control more of your
bud break. Now, it might be earlier, so
sometimes the south slope can be can be
bad, but you're going to get your
maximum daily temperature. You're going
to get a lot more foliage drying, which
will avoid a lot of your diseases.
You're going to get radiant heating,
which is going to be very beneficial.
Um, and your mid your winter
temperatures are going to be minimal.
um and your season length is going to be
as long as possible by having that south
uh slope. But
sometimes that south facing slope
because of our location we actually oh
I'd say maybe about a month ago we're
getting a lot of that sun has a lot of
warming
capabilities. So, um, what we see a lot
of times is on that south facing part of
a trunk, it it warms up, but then we,
you know, when the sun goes away, it
really drops down. That trunk has that
darker color, so it warms up, but then
we get back into the the real cold
temperatures and we cause some splitting
of the trunks. So um in those cases if
we can do something to minimize that
warming uh I think the long practice uh
with apple trees where they and some
other trees would be they go and paint
um white on the on the south facing part
of those trunks to avoid that heating up
and then cooling
down. Wind. Now we all know that North
Dakota is windy. Um maybe not this
windy, but um wind really can influence
temperature. A calm condition, as you
can see there, 18° higher temperature on
those leaves than if they're open to the
wind
blowing. And that also is really
important for the fruit because heat, it
controls the ripening. And thus we try
to get as much light
uh heat onto those uh grape clusters to
go and hasten ripening, which is very
important in North Dakota because of our
short season and the fact that we want
those um vines to start to acclimate for
dormcy as quickly as possible. So you
can use shelter belts, you can use south
sides of buildings, fences, and like
that to help go and reduce um that real
strong wind. You want a light breeze. A
light breeze isn't bad. Um but really
strong winds aren't good. Um, as far as
soil, really the only time you have to
be concerned is if you have a a hybrid
grape that has a lot of labusa in it.
Um, so Concord, something that says it
was I know they're seedless concords
that when that soil gets above seven,
they tend to show iron chlorosis.
Um, an example that we've have seen is
Bluebell, which you might have heard.
That's a Elmer Swansson one. Uh, here's
ES5471. Another Elmer Swenson one. Well,
all three of them are, but this one
never got released, but could be
available. And then Louise Swenson. All
of them have quite a bit of labus labusa
in them. Uh thus they have larger
berries kind of like concord grapes. Um
and we have seen where you'll have u
problems with some iron chlorosis. So if
you because we do tend to have soils
that are above uh a soil pH of seven. So
in those cases you need to add some
sulfur if you're trying to grow those
crops and you start to see those iron
chlorosis symptoms.
fertility. Too much fertility is a
problem because instead of going and
those vines putting that into the fruit
and into the production, it usually puts
it into canes that go to ta um uh to I
was going to say Carrington, probably
not that far. Um but Castleton and you
know just you got end up with 20 foot
long canes which isn't
needed and then starts to cause all
kinds of
problems. What I generally tell people
about 50 pounds of nitrogen per acre
um on a yearly basis. Now, in the in the
Fargo area, we have clay and and higher
organic matter. So, you need to count
that in. So, 1% organic matter releases
about 20 pounds of nitrogen per acre per
year. So, if you don't go and um in
those um soils that have higher organic
matter, if you don't go and incorporate
utilize that, you're going to be putting
way too much on um and thus have that
excess growth. I've also seen the
opposite where you know
after 10 years they haven't put on any
um nitrogen and they have a lot of grass
growing right up next to uh the vines
competing for any kind of nutrients and
out competing and thus they aren't they
don't have enough growth. They got um
canes that are only about um a foot and
a half, two foot long, and that
definitely isn't a a hybrid
grape. So,
um it's important to know what type of
grape what you want to do with these
grapes. If you're trying to make, like I
said earlier, juice, uh, jam or jelly,
uh, if they don't ripen completely, you
can go and and easily add some sugar and
and still be able to go and and make
your juice, jam, and jelly. Uh, table
grapes. the the problem with table
grapes is we don't have a lot of cold
hearty table grapes uh which are
seedless. Now if you
consider something like uh these three
that have seeds in them as table grapes
well then um but nobody wants uh grapes
to eat that have seeds and that you have
to spit seeds all the time. Uh,
University of Minnesota is working on
this. So are we on trying to introd um
find and develop some really cold hearty
um seedless table grapes. Wine wine's a
little bit more difficult because um
there's all kinds of characteristics
that you need uh those grapes to be at
when you harvest them so that you can
make a proper wine. PH is important,
titratable acidity is important, as well
as the bricks or the
sugar. Okay. Um, grapes for North
Dakota. Uh, well, of course, we know
that we need to have low temperature
tolerance. We're in a 4A, as you can see
here in the Fargo area. If we went out
west to the Williston area, they're
closer they're closer to a 3B.
Um,
and I think there's still that there's
been some uh re redoing of uh actually
the cold hardiness zones, but for the
most part, most of North Dakota is a 4A.
Um, there could be some parts that are
more 3B. Um, you need to also consider
uh your growing degree days. Uh, you can
see here now it's supposed to get colder
in Willist than it does in Fargo, but
they have more heat during the summer or
during that growing season than we do.
Just a little bit. And but the Fargo
area has a few more days that are frost
free. So, we're talking from the last
spring frost to the first spring freeze.
And once that happens, those grapes
don't ripen anymore. Um, so
um you might have a cultivar
that is marginally uh adapted to this
area. So, you see some it dies back and
that that's the worst part about it. it
dies back or um you lose all uh it
breaks bud really really early and you
lose all of those on a consistent basis
and then you don't get any fruit because
the fruit comes on the previous year's
buds. So if you don't have those buds
survive, you won't get any fruit that
year and thus you'll have one year
without as you're starting all
over. Okay, cultivars. And you can see
here I put there's like I said there's a
lot more
wine grapes available than there are um
those strictly for for juice and and um
and that's be or table. And that's
because really um for our season and for
what's available so far, it it just
that's a market that works for us. Uh
two white grapes that we recently u
introduced and released by NDSU are
Dakota Primis. Uh which you're looking
at that you're like, well, that isn't
white at all. And it it's more of a gree
as far as the color, but that skin
color, even if you were to ferment on
the skins, which you usually don't do
with whites, you'll maybe get a little
bit of more of a pinkish. and and
actually the darkness that you'll get
with this um cultivar has a lot to do
with how hot the summer is. If we don't
have a really great warm summer, um it
might be a little bit more kind of
closer to the prairie
star a and then you'll see with uh and
maybe just a little bit of uh light
reening in in those uh berries.
The other one is radiant and you can see
it looks green and um but still is is a
white wine and it may turn a little bit
more yellow similar to uh Prairie Star
as it ripens, but it's more of a it's um
more of a a a green type grape for uh
that is used for white wine.
Uh you can see there's a whole list of
things
here. Um and the only one for table is
what we call summer well it is called
Somerset seedless. It's a release by
Elmer Swenson. Um we call it somewhat
seedless because there are seed remnants
in there. Uh however um they're they're
you know really no problem whatsoever.
gives a little bit of that you can
notice it. You never would notice it in
a raisin if you dried these for raisins.
Um and so and oh if you were to dry
those for raisins, you would never buy a
storebought raisin again because these
have so much more flavor than anything
you could ever get in the store. raisins
from the store are just like little
chewy sugar drops, you know, um versus
you you really get some good grape
flavor. This year we're going to start
evaluating some of the seedless
um I'd say advanced selections from the
University of Minnesota.
uh
and you know they can't just like um
they can't put down what the numbers are
uh for uh purposes of patenting and like
that. So they called it grape r which
was the red one. And you can see how um
how that shape is. And they feel like
this is an improvement over Somerset
seedless cluster. Looks a lot similar to
Somerset Seedless. Uh grape B or blue.
Uh again, it has this uh unique uh
blueberry taste to it. And they've been
looking at it uh in processing for
frozen as well as baked. And um because
it isn't real large, you know, maybe
some mechanical harvesting because it is
rather tough though um unlike some most
of your other table grapes. You would
never consider um a red globe to go and
try to do any kind of mechanical
harvesting with that.
And then the last one is this uh G or
green um grape. And you can see it
almost to me it looks more like a lac
crescent cluster. Um and uh it talks
about having those aromatic and tropical
flavors which is a lot like lacrescent.
Um but this is a a seedless. So, uh, the
only thing I do know about these is they
they feel like they're good in zone
five. Well, which is down by the cities.
We aren't zone five. I'm going to try
these on campus where we have a little
bit more protected
um
microclimate. Uh but we'll we'll it'll
be a wait and see and maybe there's
something that we can do to try to
hasten because they all
um the harvest time is um well you can
see for the grape G it's over 3 to four
weeks but they're all towards the later
part of the season not real early so it
it will be diff um interesting to see
what happens with these three and
hopefully we can keep everyone a breast
of what's going on, let alone um we're
planting our first ones in the field
this year for seedless
um
evaluation. Okay, so let's go and start
talking about some um production. Oh
boy. Um you most of the time you're
going to go and get dormant rootstock.
They're not going to ship that to until
towards the end of May to be planted.
Maybe they'll ship it sooner and then
you have to keep it in a cooler or do
something to keep that cool um unless
you go and get those at a nursery that
has potted up plants. Um because you
only wanted one or two. Nice thing about
grapes
is almost everything that's going to be
available to you are complete flowers.
So you don't have to go and have
something go and pollinate it. So
they're not like apples. You don't need
crosspollination. So if you just wanted
one, you would you could actually just
get one. Um, if you got green material,
you want to probably wait until the end
of or until June after that May 31st,
which is usually the time for the last
the latest risk of frost in North
Dakota. Dimensions for planting, I think
that all depends on the space that you
have. Um, and again, if you're only
having a couple of plants, then a lot of
this doesn't make um isn't important for
you. Weed Whoops, got ahead of myself.
Weed control is kind of important um
because anytime you have a lot of weeds
growing around that basin um competing
with that root system, um that's not
good. Likewise, if you're going to put a
mulch down right away, don't use
something like straw.
We've done a study where we've gotten um
one-year-old dormant cutings. We put
them in the ground and we use straw as a
mulch and the microbes are going to go
and be using all the nitrogen that's in
that soil to go and break down that
straw because it has a very high carbon
to nitro or high carbon amount in
comparison to nitrogen. So those
microbes are going to need nitrogen and
the only place they're going to find it
is in the soil. So those vines will
really struggle if you use something
like um straw that first year. Now later
on, you know, when you got nice
established vines, I I suppose straw
would be just fine because
um they're just have a good root system
and you're going to be applying some of
that nitrogen on an annual basis
anyway. Uh you want to start then your
trellis construction afterwards. And uh
but really that first year all you're
trying to do is get those vines
established. A lot of people will say,
"Oh, do I go and put well let me go and
do I go and put road tubes around them?"
Yes. If you have problems with anything
like rabbits,
um deer, then this is going to be
helpful. What we found is that a grow
tube isn't
necessarily needed. Um, as long
as you're you're um acclimating if
you're using plants, they're acclimated
before you put them out there and thus
aren't going to go and be thrown into a
different kind of
environment. for as long as you don't
have a lot of those little critters that
want to go and destroy everything for
you. So, the first year we're really
working on the root growth. I wouldn't
do any pruning. I wouldn't try I just
try to keep them growing as much as
possible because that they're uh
whatever you get for the root starting
there, it's going to be the basis.
That's going to be like your foundation
for your house. you have a poor
foundation, the rest of the house isn't
going to stand up very well. Second
year's going to start working on your
vine architecture, doing some pruning,
and you might leave a few clusters to
taste, but really most of those clusters
you should remove because you're still
working on that foundation. Finally,
your third year, you can go and keep
your fruit.
I'm going to go over that because I
could see how much lack of time I have.
Um, and again, those kind of m trellis
materials all depend on how many vines
you're going to get and and um and your
location, but you're going to need
something. Uh, even though I say they
have a
trunk, they don't have a really good
they need support. So, you need to find
some way of supporting these so that
they're upright. And stuff to consider
are, you know, your physical limitations
on on how you're going to grow them. Can
you go and put them on a high wire that
generally is six foot tall? Well, do you
want to always have your hands up in the
air when you're working on those? Do you
want them maybe a little bit lower? you
want to maybe go with a midwire and
train everything to grow
upwards and thus have that fruit um at
that midwire which is about three foot.
All of those things are
important. Okay, pruning. It's important
that you go and have balanced pruning
because um you need to control your
crop.
Um, most of the time you'll remove 80%.
You can see it almost looks like maybe
90% of what was there. Um, because if
you don't, you're going to overcrop it.
And especially in in North Dakota,
that's really important that you don't
overcrop. Um,
um, yeah. bud fruitfulness. Also,
another thing on um so having all that
growth and like that if you didn't go
and take any of these uh canes off from
the previous year, that means you're
going to have lots and lots of layers of
leaves. And the more shading onto those
clusters, the less fruitful those buds
will be um at on those clusters, the
slower they'll ripen. But also those
nodes and buds for next year, they'll
get less light too. So they're going to
be less fruitful. So sunlight exposure
is really, really
important. Here shows differences for
different locations. Generally, we use
this 30 + 10 for any kind of grapes we
grow, especially the wine grapes in in
North Dakota. And that plus 10 means if
you get more than
uh two pounds of pruning from that wood,
oh, one pound pruning. What am I I
getting off? So, um No. So, if you if
you're pruning and from a vine you get
more than two pounds of pruning, you can
add 10 more buds and have a total of 40
for this. But we're using this lowest
one right here
um
for almost all of ours. Now, if you've
got more than 2 lb and you're way up
here at at 4 lb
um and you can see um where we have, you
know, the um number of fruit like that,
you are this means you're
undercropping and you're you're not
leaving enough fruit. But if you're way
up here,
um then you're overcropping. I always
try if I have two pounds per vine and we
take out just a little fish scale. After
a little bit, you you don't even need
that scale. You kind of know what's
what. Um but 30 + 10 is lot what we use.
And I'm not going to go over all this
because I can see I'm already at that
time. Um some
characteristics. Shoot density. So per
foot of shoot or canopy.
um you want three to five shoots to be
coming out. So that means um three to
five nodes per foot more on that you
know hopefully on that usually in a foot
you can get three nodes. If you get more
than that
um it it means that that vine might be
under stress that it has shorter
nodes. Well I'm going to go over that um
chute thinning. Okay. So, this is done
to open the canopy, but it all depends
on what kind of trellis. If you have
your um trunk going up and then you put
out cordons or arms and thus have uh
just removing most of that cane wood
leaving two shoots at each of these what
is called spurs.
What happens on that is then as those
vines grow, they get longer, you comb
them down, and then when they're about
to touch the ground, you want to go and
prune that off.
Um, they talk about a lot of times
shootute thinning before those canes get
18 in long. That's because you don't
need um that much. You need 15 to 20
leaves to to go and ripen those two to
three clusters that's on a chute. All
that extra is is
just extra stuff that might help might
go and actually go and cover up and
shade a lot of that. The problem is
minute you start doing some pruning you
get what is called lateral shoots. These
have no kind of fruit on them and they
start to shade things out.
So shootute
thinning a lot of times is very helpful
on on going and keeping enough light
onto these and removing those lateral
shoots. It comes to a lot of work. Some
people will even actually remove leaves
that are around the clusters to help
expose those grapes to um that uh uh the
sunlight to those
clusters. Crop thinning. Well,
um oh, but if you're going to go and
remove those leaves, you don't wait
until you know the clusters are really
huge. you need to start before you get
to verasion because otherwise
um and maybe you only do it on the west
side or or on the um east side. The west
side is going to be warmer than the east
side. So you remove them on the east
side to help get those um leaves or the
clusters a little bit warmer and you
don't have to worry as much about
suncalding or sunburning those clusters.
um crop
thinning. If you're going to do
something like that, you you would do
that, you uh would wait until about four
weeks after fruit set. Fruit set occurs
in um early June. So, um so by early
July, you would know whether or not you
have way too many clusters to go and get
them ripen in time. And then then you
can start to go and oh, I got three
clusters on this cane. I don't need all
three. I'm going to just remove one and
keep two. A lot of times one to two
clusters per cane is good.
So, and of course you always want to if
sometimes there's a stress and they
might throw out some more late clusters
or do some flowering and then you have
um some late clusters, always remove
those because they're just going to go
and cause
problems. Okay, last little bit Fred.
Okay, herbicide injury by 24D is going
to be can be really common. Grapes are
really susceptible to 24D, even more so
than dicama. So, you see this fanning
and if they're in your backyard, there's
a lot of people using 24D on their
lawns. Thus, you might see something
like this happening.
Um
birds, especially for homeowners, you
might need to do some netting because uh
birds really like grapes. They like a
lot of fruit. So, and when you only have
one to
two, that really puts a target on those.
So, dear raccoon rabbits, I'm going to
questions. I did poor Tom.
Sorry,
I warned you. You're You're just too
knowledgeable. Got too much information
to share. Well, I got too many stories,
I think. I know. It's because of all
your years of working with this prop.
Now, listen. So, we got rapid fire
questions. Really quick answers. We're
going to be done in five minutes. Okay,
Arlene. First of all, would any grape
varieties work well in a high tunnel?
The problem with that all of these if
they're hardy enough for outside they're
they're good for a high tunnel. The
thing that you can't do is you can't
think because I have a high tunnel um
which is going to give you more heat
that you're going to go and be able to
have something less hardy cold hearty
because in the winter
um especially at night you don't have
that the plastic doesn't retain that
heat. So your outside temperature is
going to be the same as what's going to
be in that high tunnel. Uh, thus okay,
that's good. Pick a hardy variety.
They'll all work. They have to be
hearty. This person is, is a grape
seedless due to genetics or is it seed
or can I make a grape variety seedless
by eliminating manganesees away from the
plant? No genetics. It's genetics. Now,
what was that variety you liked for
raisins? Oh, Somerset seedless. Yeah,
you want a seedless variety. And that's
really the only hardy reliable hearty
variety we got. Now this person lived in
Dickinson and they grew Fontineac Gree
Prairie Star and Lac Crescent. But now
they moved to West Fargo. Which one of
those would that would you recommend?
Oh, actually all three of them would be
even better. we get more rainfall and um
and so um depends if they w you know L
crescent is more fruity but if you if we
ever get a really bad winter then L
crescent has it really likes to throw
out volcanes and uh uh it can be
difficult but all three of them um front
or front gree will will make more of a a
straw colored wine
But they could do all three of them
would be fine. West Fargo, this person
has an old neglected grape vine. Should
they cut it to the ground or just dig it
out? Uh, you can rejuvenate old grapes,
grape vines. Um, but you're going to
again, um, what happens with old vines
is that if you haven't done anything,
it's only that one year old wood that's
going to have fruit. So you're going to
have to do some major cutting back um
and then keep pruning. So I would u cut
it back to uh generally we like to have
two arms and do cordons. Uh you might
have uh you know do a little bit more
cutting back. Also, you could also work
at a lot of times they'll set up a um a
sucker will come up from the
base, make that your new trunk, and then
you can go and lop off everything else
or two trunks.
How about uh when's the best time to
prune a grape vine? Before it starts to
um open the buds. Those buds become
really easy just to knock off. So, um,
now we just had a pruning clinic, uh,
by, um, air, um,
yesterday and they were still dormant
and so this is a good time. Other people
go out when it's colder and they have
their gloves on, but boy, this kind of
weather is just perfect. If you can go
and get it done quickly, do it now. Are
all grape leaves edible for Greek
recipes?
Yeah, but I would probably avoid the
ones that have all the white tomatoss on
the backside. I don't think those would
be as tasty as something that um isn't
as pubescent on the underside. Okay. How
about what variety is best for up north
in the Turtle Mountains?
Oh, well, what are they trying to do
with it? Well, ju I would guess juice.
Okay. um our only choice. Our overall
our our heartiest grapes that we've ever
tested are valiant and king of the
north.
Um it's good. Is spotted winged a
concern with grapes?
Not unless you have problems where with
rainfall in the fall that you start to
get little fissures or little openings
by where they attach to the stem that
then um valiant has been the only grape
that we've seen anyone report um spotted
Wayne Drosophila. And again, um, we feel
like it was because of some rainfall
which then put a crack and then the
spotted winged or soft said, "Hey, thank
you." and laid some eggs. Start my own
grape vine from a wild grape and just
take a cutting and stick it in a pot and
get started. Yeah, you can. Okay, that's
good. What's the best mulch you would
use in an established vine? Shredded
bark. Uh shredded bark would be good.
Yep. Um because the and the larger the
chunks, the the slower the degradation
would occur. How about Marshall Foch?
Are those Marshall Foch? Are those
seedless? No, that is a French American
wine grape. Yeah, that's not a party
here, is it? Or it's marginal. Uh kind
of iffy. Yeah, not looking the best out
in our variety trial. Okay, well that's
going to do it for for this
presentation. Thank you. Was loaded with
information. I couldn't get to all the
questions, but you can contact Harleen
and or you can contact your local county
agent. They can help you and also
myself. We'll be happy to help you.
Okay. Thank you, Harleen, so much.